that is at a certain moment in your
lecture you say or you argue that Europe
is now the scenario of this unsettling
spectacle the re-emerge of extremist
nationalistic say no phobic and racist
right which do not believe in democratic
principles would it not be more
democratic to say look if this is what
the people want we have to accept it
because this is what the majority of the
people want well we we defend ourselves
believe in for example that or all
totalitarian regimes were in popular
that the majority of societies which
fall in the hands of extremists and
fanatical governments we're against
those governments resisting now the
fanaticism of the minority which took
power this is a lie this is not true
Hitler was very popular he won the
election with just a third of the
electorate but very few years after he
was enormously popular he had the
majority of the population with him
Mussolini was not popular Mussolini was
extremely popular the worst dictators
that we have had in Latin America real
monsters like Trujillo in the Dominican
Republic he was enormously popular
enormously popular in my country
to my shame Fujimori when he became a
dictator he was very popular he was very
popular and people who were against will
amore were insulted in the streets of
Lima as myself so this is the true the
true is that a society is not always not
eternally democratic it can become
democratic
but it can move towards the extremes
given certain circumstances I can
definitely add to what we have just
heard from Mario my own experience I
come from Israel 62 years old always a
democracy ever since it was founded it
has remained a democracy which is quite
an achievement for its generation but
always a democracy under siege from
outside and from within and if there is
any lesson we can draw from our everyday
struggle about democracy it is that
majoritarian rule is only one gist of
democracy and anyone who thinks the
democracy is about majority is making a
tragic mistake
the other great pillar of democracy is
always in alienable egalitarian civil
and human rights if you leave that out
you have forgotten what democracy is
about whether it is in Israel or in
European countries I would second that
very strongly
the idea of majority rule which is of
the essence of democracy has to become a
car company and I believe
institutionally accompanied structurally
accompanied by protections of certain
rights majority rule has to come for
example with minority rights at the same
time one of the great dangers however it
seems to me is that the idea of
democracy which is the idea of
self-government by the citizens of a
country as the final authority of
legitimacy should not be stolen and
stolen particularly by forces that use
democratic terms for anti-democratic
purposes and it's a sort of thing I
think one needs to worry about is Italy
still no democracy no
no now I think Italy is not a real
democracy there are a struggle for
democracy with with large sections of
the population that are for democracy
but now from an institutional point of
view we can't consider in in the classic
turns Italy still a democracy democracy
is really and deeply jeopardized in
Italy because when you have a system of
media that has only a parallel in Europe
that his Putin's Russia this already is
not a democracy we have still judges
that are autonomous from the political
power but for that they are more and
more intimidated they had to be almost
the heroes and democracy needs not to
have heroes but normal citizens and when
corruption becomes not only incredibly
enlarged it but the a sort of proud
because Berlusconi didn't done doesn't
negate that the corruption of his
friends and he he explained that one has
to be proud not to pay taxes for
instance this is not a normal right
party this is
something that changed changed
completely the mood of politics and I
think there is a certain risk of
confusion with these questions is Italy
still a democracy is United States a
democracy I think you can put this kind
of questions only if you don't know what
a dictatorship is is a Peruvian Latin
America I'm an expert on dictatorships
and and I love really when when I hear
these questions apply to countries which
are deeply democratic very imperfect
democracies of course Italy very
imperfect I have no sympathy for
Berlusconi I think it's very sad that a
country with cultural tradition of Italy
has a crown and was a very corrupt crown
as president of his government but Italy
is still a democracy because you can
criticize Berlusconi all these spaces in
which there is freedom are used by
oppositus through two values Kony and to
criticize fiercely his traffics and his
grotesque spectacles and evil in US and
you still can change the government
elections you still control there is the
possibility of an alternate sin in power
because the structures of basic
structures of democracy democracy are
there it is true that we the electorate
because I think the with the frustration
of the leftist governments of Italy with
were so inept opened their arms to
Berlusconi very sad but you cannot say
and you can not compare in spite of the
corruption in spite of the majority of
Italy with a real dictatorship
this is really
an astronomical different kind of thing
I didn't confirmed anything because I
answered the question is Italy still a
democracy and my answer is yet is no but
I never said that in Italy there is a
dictatorship I started my say with the
words the Berlusconi's Italy is not
fascism but between fascism with all the
violence the street violence and so on
and democracy even a non-perfect
democracy like in France like in Spain
like in Germany like in Netherlands
there is a space for a third possibility
a non democracy of course I can write
every day
on a newspaper but since only 10% of
Italian people read newspapers including
sport newspaper that means that 90% is
informant only by TV and when on TV you
have a sort of Bulgarian property of
Berlusconi on media this changed
completely the the idea of liberal
democracy that for instance had
Jefferson head or and so you can't you
can't realistically speak of Italy as a
democracy in the normal European sense
exist
must be something really wrong with a
liberal left in Europe and elsewhere if
we are using such words as democracy or
fascism in order to trump our own hopes
for our own future saying that democracy
doesn't exist anymore it has been said
around the table about certain countries
it's been said often in my country
saying that and leaving it a threat is a
measure of desperation is a measure of
impoverishment moral and intellectual
and if this is the liberal left then I
would like to be to be look to a more
vocal part of it a more hopeful part of
it but it has future horizons so it's
not useful I think it's simply not
useful let alone a question of academic
analysis what do we call democracy what
is a democracy
it's simply totally unuseful damaging to
say help my country democracy is gone
they've taken my country away what can I
do usually the answer is let me become a
cynic and enjoy life while I can and so
many young Europeans are saying now and
even parts of tel-aviv are beginning to
say no this is a totally wrong attitude
not only do I agree with Mario that you
have to see a real adamant non democracy
in order to appreciate what you really
do still have but you have to become
much more active and proactive about
fighting for what you have very few
people here I've mentioned social
democracy so let me just say that let me
remind you that with all its
shortcomings and I come from a keyboard
I know what utopian dream of socialism
is and what I would slim it but social
democracy historically has been the best
Trump against xenophobia social
democracy I mean with all respect and I
know it quite well but both here in the
Netherlands any France any need to be
and exist it doesn't exist
doesn't exist let me just answer very
briefly and this will be conclude also
my response Rob as a person who has you
ghosts reawakening is such a wonderful
metaphor never say about anything that
it is dead least of all social democracy
that's really hopeful hungry